alors d'accord après avoir été une star
du x désormais une autre passion la bi
le cheval voici les gidley
et
bonsoir alors tu as fait quarante films
x en quatre ans comment après ça tu pu
renouer des relations normales avec les
hommes
c'est à dire mais bon on reste dans le
même domaine at a publié deux bouquins
après mois le scandaleuse d'abord chez
filipacchi qui est un certain succès et
puis la femme modèle chez j'ai lu qui
est un roman qui parle de quoi alors
c'est une femme mariée très rangée et
tout et puis qui s'emmerdent quoi est
elle se met à poser pour des
photographes amateurs
il ya le découvre comme ça plein
d'autres choses et sa vie sa vie démarre
c'est le contraire de moi en fait moi je
me suis rangé après la liste est rangée
avant moi je fais du cinéma aussi tu as
fait quoi at il fait plein de choses
humaines tournée pour l'afsset
tu vois finalement la fed vous regrettez
que toujours la recette déjà pu être
bien ouais j'ai tourné pour tf1 jamais
pour le cinéma
ça fait quoi au cinéma j'ai fait les
prédateurs de la nuit l'exécutrice jeu
plein plein d'autres je fais de la scène
avec un truc n'a pas très bien marché
faut le dire que j'appelais des parfums
de scandale dans un petit café théâtre
et puis c'était c'est dieu oui et puis
là maintenant je suis au théâtre des
deux ânes
j'ai entendu un nom c'est ainsi qu'est
ce qu'y avait-il annoncé les deux hommes
qui me font marrer à vendargues gars qui
s'appelle cresson qui s'en dédit avec
jacques mailhot ouais mais qui marche
très très bien
ça marche très fort